foreign
people using the latest in technology we
are live on the electronic computer
machine I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's Friday so we've got
another round table Extravaganza for you
joining me today is a columnist for the
New York Post and Fox News Carol
Markowitz and the politics editor at
Chronicles magazine and a subset sub
stack essayist for Contra Pedro Gonzalez
Carol Pedro welcome to the urban report
hi thanks for having us good to be here
Pedro this is your tryout first time
Reuben report person and uh you know
it's it's all dependent your entire
career is dependent on the next half
hour are you ready I look forward to
disappointing you like I disappoint my
mother
and Carol never disappoints anybody so
let's just dive right into it uh the big
sort of cultural story of the week was
that Elon Musk went after uh Palpatine
like George Soros uh in an interview on
CNBC after the Tesla shareholder meeting
in Austin Texas uh and then he continued
it on Twitter uh here's a bit of the
interview from CNBC because once you
criticize George Soros somehow you're
automatically an anti-semite or
something like that here we go how do
you make a choice you don't see I mean
in terms of when you're going to engage
I mean for example even today Elon you
you tweeted this thing about George
Soros
or I'm looking for because I want to
make sure I quote it properly but I mean
you know what you wrote but you
basically it reminds me of my videos is
like you know calm down people this is
not like medical I could put my face out
of it
he said he wants to erode the very
fabric of civilization and Soros hates
Humanity like when you do something like
that yeah I think that's true that's my
opinion okay but why share it why share
it especially I mean why share it when
people who buy Teslas may not agree with
you advertisers on Twitter may not agree
with you
um why not just say hey I think this you
can tell me we can talk about it over
there you can tell your friends but why
share it widely
I mean I this is freedom of speech I'm
allowed to say whatever you absolutely
are but I'm trying to understand why you
do because you have to know it's Gotta
there it puts you in a in the middle of
a the partisan divide in the country it
makes you a lightning rod for criticism
I mean do you like that I you know
people today saying he's an anti-semite
I don't think you are no I'm definitely
I'm like I'm like a pro Semite if
anything I'll say what I want to say and
if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it
I have to say you know Elon had a bit of
a weird week because he did hire this
CEO from NBC Universal who seems like
she might be kind of woke and I I keep
trying to give him the benefit of the
doubt but so let's put that one aside
for a second but his answer there yeah I
think it's true and that's my opinion
and the interviewer just does not want
him to share his opinion he even says it
why share it Pedro it's crazy that
people share their opinions in America
in 2023 isn't it yeah yeah and I think
there's this kind of debate over
does Soros wake up every morning and do
this kind of self-affirmation like I
will destabilize democracy
I think that that debate is not really
useful because we can actually just look
at what he does and and what he
accomplishes with his money and his
influence and so specifically the issue
of of soros-backed prosecutors District
Attorneys right so there are about 75 of
these people in the United States
now that sounds like a small number but
it's actually extremely consequential
because those 75 people represent one in
every five Americans or over 70 million
people across half of the 50 most
populous cities in the country uh
because these District Attorneys their
jurisdictions are either counties or
groups of counties right so with all of
that under uh under consideration you're
talking about a group of people who
oversees 40 percent of homicides in this
country
and so we can actually evaluate whether
or not Soros is a good or bad guy when
we look at these prosecutors and we see
that they're doing things like not
Prosecuting violent offenders letting
people go uh implementing these these
trial policies and these plea deals and
these these basically allowing people to
get off for violent crimes with a kind
of slap on the wrist we don't have to
guess whether or not Soros is actually a
bad guy we can just look at what he's
doing I mean think of obviously everyone
is familiar with Alvin Bragg right now
but think about Larry krasner in
Philadelphia a guy who oversaw a
historic uh murder wave and there's just
been a this attempt to uh impeach him
but so far it's been unsuccessful like
these people are deeply entrenched and
they're only there because of Sorrows
and his money right and also we could
mention George gascon who was the D.A in
San Francisco who now who wrecked San
Francisco now is wrecking La as the D.A
and the guy that they impeached or they
got rid of recalled uh Chessa Bodine in
San Francisco uh Carol this notion that
somehow if you criticize Soros you're an
anti-semite is so patently ridiculous
that would be like saying if you
criticize Dave Chappelle you're you're
anti-black or if you criticize Anderson
Cooper you're anti-gay actually we have
a tweet here from amahi chikli he and uh
he he's in Israel's government he wrote
as Israel's Minister who's entrusted on
combating anti-Semitism I would like to
clarify that the Israeli government and
the vast majority of Israeli citizens
see Elon Musk as an amazing entrepreneur
and role model criticism of Soros who
finances the most hostile organizations
to the Jewish people in the state of
Israel is anything but anti-Semitism
quite the opposite so meanwhile you've
got an Israeli Minister who this is his
gig to make sure that people are in
hating the Jews he's on the side of Elon
Musk but our entire leftist media
machine is now calling Elon Musk and
anti-semite that's it it's first of all
I love Israelis I love that like we love
Ilan livilan Alone
um just perfect
um I you know it's interesting because
Soros isn't like doing this in the
shadows he had a Wall Street Journal
piece about a year ago last July saying
hey I fund these prosecutors and here's
why so this isn't like a conspiracy
theory he admits to this and he has his
reasons for it and I think it's okay to
criticize him and his reasons and the
thing that Elon is saying that he's
being destructive to civilization this
is true we see this in the news we watch
this happen all the time tying it to
Soros is showing look this is where the
funding for these bad ideas comes from
and the fact that he's Jewish is such a
side issue like when does he ever talk
about his Judaism I mean it's like
literally I don't even associate him
with Judaism at all and if we can't
criticize Jews I don't know I don't
think anybody should be criticizing me
or you because obviously that's
anti-semitic obviously to read to
reiterate Pedro's point on that here
here's what I tweeted out uh the
simplest way to look at the simplest way
to look at it meaning this whole
situation is what DA's he's financially
backed and what they subsequently did to
democrat-run cities it's one thing to be
a misguided 20 year old with good
intentions it's another to be his age
with his track record and supposedly
have them too point is there is no legit
rationale for his actions unless you
want to upend Western democracies which
he's doing quite well look at his track
record and then I link to a daily mail
piece over there that has some of the
numbers that you reference Pedro is
there any version of Soros that we're
not giving credit to is he just
misguided I hear a lot of people say
well his intentions are good he doesn't
want people to rot in jail so he sends
them out onto the street right yeah he
just he foists uh rapists and murderers
on us out of the kindness of his heart I
actually again I don't I can't read his
mind uh and there are other billionaires
like him there are other
um philanthropists with you know quote
quotation marks around that word that
are doing this but Soros is just the
most notorious and I think it's just
because he's also probably the most
prolific in the sense
um it's become like his Elemental
purpose to do this but it's not just
crime obviously it's also immigration he
uses money to basically hack political
systems and and bypass the rule of law
that's why countries like Hungary have
passed stop Soros laws which are
essentially intended to to stop his
money from being used to facilitate uh
Mass immigration because again that's a
violation of a country's sovereignty for
the record he was born in Hungary that's
right yeah that's right
um
no I mean you you have a guy who again
we can evaluate what he's actually doing
independent of the rhetoric using words
like democracy and openness and things
like that what is what does Soros
actually accomplish he he makes our
quality of life worse he gets people
killed he makes the United States a
place where crime has become the norm
and where we're not even allowed to
comment on it anymore because it's a
it's it's considered a kind of
anti-Semitism just by the fact that he's
Jewish Harold Carol one last thought on
this just bringing it back to Elon for a
second just doesn't it strike you as
just deeply refreshing that not only is
he willing to do these interviews but
the way he answers the questions where
you can see he's thinking it through in
real time he's saying hey this is my
opinion and the fact that the the
interviewer it doesn't I don't even know
his name it doesn't even matter that
he's so on the side of people's
self-censoring which is probably the
biggest problem that we have in America
right now yeah interviewer would have no
have no problem if Elon Musk was selling
the opposite
today that we should defend George Soros
criticizing George Soros is anti-Semitic
that interviewer will be cheering him on
and talking about how he's talking truth
to power but instead he's trying to shut
down elon's point of view and Elon
catches that he I really have a soft
spot for him also sidebar but his new
CEO follows me on Twitter so how bad
could she be
um oh right you were on the list when it
came out that she might be a kind of
woke Lefty you were on the list of
people that she followed so people were
kind of like oh she may not be that bad
and we'll see we'll see right I love
Elon I think that what he's doing is
really refreshing and I love seeing
somebody just say what they think and
not have to clear it with their PR team
so the other big story this week
obviously was the Durham report coming
out let's just dive into it real quick
daily wire special counselor John Durham
who was tasked by former Attorney
General Bill Barr to examine the
propriety of the FBI's investigation of
President Trump released a 320-page
report on Monday that found the FBI had
no evidence to support a trump-russia
scandal when it began its investigation
and found sobering differences in how it
approached the Trump probe compared to
other politically sensitive
investigations
Pedro am I some sort of uh genius or
person from the future in that I never
fell for this thing and people could go
back to all of my videos for the past
six years and never find me buying what
obviously was completely nonsensical
yeah no and honestly it's interesting
because this this should be something
that is like really sort of shocking but
it's not for exactly that reason it's
like this is not really news and I think
that's why there was there was this I
think the maybe again I didn't see all
of it but it that's the impression I got
from the reaction to it was it was just
kind of people you know sign that like
yeah we knew that
um but I guess that the reason I haven't
really gotten kind of you know in uh
upset about it I guess is because I I
don't want to just get angry about this
about this attempt by the Deep state to
do whatever I I actually want
accountability and I think there's a
problem now and this is kind of an
outsider take on this issue but the the
problem on the right is that we I think
we like just getting really angry about
things and then never holding anybody
accountable or getting serious enough to
hold people accountable and that's kind
of where I'm at it's like yes of course
they did this of course it was wrong and
unethical and horrible but now what
I I don't want to just get angry about
it yeah is that really the issue I mean
I say that on the show all the time we
can have hearings about everything we
can expose Twitter files all of the
stuff always we can all turn out to be
right three years later after being
called conspiracy theorists but to
Pedro's Point nothing happens I mean
that's what I kept thinking all week all
right congratulations we got the info
that we thought yeah nobody's gonna get
fired doesn't matter you know I'm not
going to wait for big structural changes
I would love to see obviously
accountability on a bigger level
um but on a smaller level I want
everybody who fell for these hoaxes
every time they say anything I want us
to say you thought Donald Trump was a
Russian spy so just disqualify all of
their future opinions that's what they
do to us that's why Media Matters exist
and so we they catch us saying something
that's like wrong or inappropriate or
whatever and then they use that line to
disqualify everything that we say going
forward I don't see why we don't do that
to them have the list of people who said
absolutely insane things about Donald
Donald Trump's connection to Russia and
hold them accountable like that for the
rest of their lives
so the other thing that happened this
week and it's sort of related to that is
there was a congressional hearing on the
weaponization of government and a couple
FBI whistleblowers have come out and
what we're going to play for you right
now is unbelievably extraordinary and
again the question is will anything
happen uh basically a whistleblower
saying yeah we can't release all the all
those tapes that Tucker got because we
were pretty much in on it take a look
those individuals were inside the
capitol to which the SSA responded back
and I was privy to these conversations
firsthand why can't you show us
why can't you just send us that give us
access to the 11 000 hours of video of
this exam that's available because there
may be maybe
uc's undercover officers or chs's
confidential unit for confidential human
sources on those videos whose identity
we need to protect
so Mr Allen you got
oh hot damn it turns out there were a
whole bunch of undercover FBI agents on
top of the fact that we saw police
officers moving barricades opening doors
for people welcome welcoming them into
the capital uh again Pedro I have a
feeling I know your opinion on this uh
you're not shocked and you don't think
anything's gonna happen
yeah I actually my opinion is probably
even worse than what you had hoped and
that's basically again this is a
situation where I'm really sick of of
just getting angry about things and
never holding anybody accountable and I
think this revolves around the whole
stolen election narrative and I've
basically come to the position that look
the election
wasn't stolen it was given away
and we now have these reports that are
coming out in places like the Washington
Post and by the way the liberal media is
good now right because you know we've
we've got people like Donald Trump
saying that
um right the school the liberal media
reported that the Trump campaign
actually hired two different teams to
investigate the the Integrity of the
results in 2020 and at least one of
those teams concluded that the Trump
campaign hired at least one of those
teams concluded before the January 6th
stuff before the rally was held that the
devolved into you know this what you
could argue was a situation where there
were undercover uh federal agents who
are maybe probably goading uh people to
doing things that ultimately got them in
jail well before that even happened the
Trump campaign was made aware by the
people it hired that they could not find
enough fraud to argue that the the
election had been swung in some way for
Biden now I think Democrats did do
things that were unethical uh but they
but I think it's not a surprise everyone
before the 2020 election happened knew
the Democrats were going to do something
whether it was ballot harvesting or law
fair or whatever and they did but there
was no countermeasures taken and so
basically you had the situation where
the Trump campaign internally knew that
basically Democrats had just outfoxed
them because they wanted to win more and
that's ultimately what matters right
who's in the White House and still held
this rally that devolved into a
situation where you it looks like you
had undercover federal agents that were
helping this thing turn into an out of
control riot and that's why I can't just
participate in this this ridiculous kind
of endless thing of outrage and I mean
in the background of all this Donald
Trump just defended hiring Christopher
Wray and his defense was well Chris
Christie and the Democrats told me it
was a good idea he can't bring himself
to say it was a mistake to put someone
like Christopher Ray in charge of the
FBI at the same time that we're supposed
to get angry at the FBI for hanging
Undercovers uh at January 6. I mean it's
not my obviously my position is not the
one a lot of people want to hear but
it's just really hard to get angry and
and just participate in this outrage
machine when you have all of these other
facts to consider well because kind of
what you're saying there is that Trump
was sort of in on it in that he knew
they weren't going to reverse the
results of the election and he
internally knew that he had lost but he
still set up the people and to some
degree he had to know that there were
going to be agents in there I mean again
this is one of those things that on
January 6 as it was happening I was like
this does not seem legit they are moving
barricades literally welcoming them in
into the people's house Carol yeah
a friend who went to this on January 6
to cover it as a reporter and what they
say is they're like when I go to a July
4th parade at the nation's capital there
are police every five feet here there
was nothing and they were like we're out
of here and left the event
um I I think that that's really the
thing is that we all kind of know that
it was definitely you know not what we
saw on television but there are not
going to be any consequences to this and
The Whistleblower report like has barely
been mentioned even in the news it's
like doesn't even exist the the
testimony of the whistleblowers is
something that nobody's being paying any
attention to it's disheartening because
I like to think of myself as very like I
believe in America I believe in our
systems I believe in our you know
institutions and just the failure at
every level for the last few years has
to be disheartening and I I see people
opting out of public life up opting out
of like even social life because they
have such a Negative opinion of what's
going on with our institutions I I don't
know that they could be rebuilt maybe
that that's just impossible but I I
would love to see a country where we
trust institutions again Pedro what
about how this over time will just
degrade these institutions completely
because if you're a young person that
might want to work at the FBI or the CIA
and you're watching these hearings right
now you're probably if you're a true
patriot if you believe in America
believe in the institutions as Carl
saying how could you how could you take
that job
yeah I think well you're already seeing
this across basically every institution
like that I mean like the military is
having awful recruitment problems and
it's it's you know it's hard to figure
out why the military is having a hard
time getting people to sign up to die
for this for exactly what we're
discussing basically a system that's run
by people that hate everyday Americans
that's what you're supposed to give your
life for that's what you're supposed to
put everything on the line for
um so yeah I mean I think we're
witnessing a kind of the the Free Fall
of institutional credibility in the
United States and that's really
difficult to to fix
um it certainly requires better and more
capable leadership but again this is
something that's been a long time coming
and it's not going to be fixed overnight
uh this is I think the beginning of a
kind of long and sad decline for
institutional credibility
Donald Trump supporters who are not
planning to vote because they no longer
believe that our elections are worth
anything these are older people who have
voted in every election
um they want Donald Trump to win and
they're not planning to vote so you know
who we're shooting ourselves in the face
I mean this is this is what's happening
on the right
yeah well all right so to that point
let's talk a little bit about uh this
upcoming election because it does sound
like our Fair Governor Carroll uh Ron
DeSantis is going to jump in probably in
the next couple days got a little info
here from your paper the New York Post
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis will
officially enter the race for president
next week the post has learned setting
up a much anticipated Face-Off with his
one-time Ally former president Donald
Trump after months of speculation about
a White House run DeSantis 44 will fire
the required paperwork with the Federal
Election Commission before holding an
announcement event in his hometown of
Dunedin according to Sunshine a Sunshine
State Legislative Source the prospective
filing coincides with a two-day meeting
between DeSantis and his donors in Miami
where attendees are being told they'll
be put to work the source added that
desantis's official announcement will be
followed by a staggered rollout of
endorsements that have been held in
reserve until he gets in the race the
DeSantis supporting Never Back Down pack
previously announced the Florida
governor has been endorsed by dozens of
legislators legislatures in early voting
state states of Iowa and New Hampshire
Pedro the first part I want to mention
about that is the 44. he is 44 years old
I am 46 years old that means I'm older
than him we are used to be governed uh
being governed by you know people in
their late 70s 80s and and sometimes in
their 90s uh it's kind of refreshing
isn't it
yeah that was my first thought actually
when I was looking at that screen grab
was 44.
um and it's just so funny because this
DeSantis is the santis is basically the
the exact opposite of of what both Joe
Biden and Trump represent uh this kind
of um and I mean we're going to get into
this but and part of it is precisely
that the scientist is Being Framed as a
kind of Trojan Horse by by the Trump
campaign
um but right now you've got this kind of
funny situation where Trump who's
supposed to be the anti-establishment
guy is actually in many ways kind of
legitimizing the old sclerotic GOP
establishment and its ideas and on the
other hand you've got this young upstart
that actually threatens to kind of upset
the apple cart and that's for I mean
that seems to me pretty obvious why he's
so hated by the I mean the actual
establishment GOP which has fallen in
line behind Trump I mean it's a it's an
incredible situation because of the
level of gaslighting that's gone in to
convince you that DeSantis represents
the old order uh and and these two older
guys or I guess specifically Trump
represents the New Order
a version of that as I keep saying would
be that Trump is on the side of the
mainstream media at this point he did a
CNN Town Hall despite the fact he'll
tell you CNN is evil and he's literally
posting links to Joy Reed's website
MSNBC Joy Reed noted racist from MSNBC
Joy on on his truth Social account uh
Carol look you very publicly we got here
the same week to Florida uh you came
from New York I came from Cali uh you've
seen the good life here for a year and a
half I take it you're pleased about
what's about to happen
yeah I mean I'm you know I walk around
smiling but look I I can't make any
decisions about 2024 until I hear what
Krista Nunu is going to be doing and
Chris Christie yeah I have to see are
they running or what's going on with
that
um well Chris Christie's not running I
promise you that
person Nunu Christy
is announced in the same day so
see that there's
a person actually in this race and
really they don't belong in it
um I I think that what DeSantis has done
in Florida has been revolutionary I feel
like we're in a revolution down here
we're seeing things from our government
that I just never expected to see I
things like you know I was in my son's
public school classroom today and like
it is a classic classroom where not a
single piece of nonsense on any of the
walls not a single like trans flag or
BLM sign or anything and I know I came
from Brooklyn and Brooklyn's crazy but
I'm so used to
um just being on guard and like thinking
like I'm gonna look around and see
something I don't like and you know the
worst thing about it was there was a
toilet Taylor Swift poster but I think
we can live with that and the normalcy
here and just the way that that DeSantis
promotes that normalcy is amazing well
that's the incredible thing to me
because they're trying to frame normalcy
and competency and decency as radicalism
or somehow this right wing lunacine it's
just not true Carol I want to play a
clip you were on Jordan Peterson's
podcast about a week ago and you guys
got into why it's important to fight the
culture wars and why certain people
don't and why certain people do I think
that's definitely related to what's
going on here in Florida take a look
conservatives are so damn blind that
this goes on under their noses
constantly and they often facilitate its
movement forward
and it's because they're they're either
ignorant that's part of the problem or
they're afraid on the moral front and
neither of those are excusable
especially when hypothetically they're
concerned about losing the cultural War
which they are definitely losing well
look at the abuse and pushback that
Governor DeSantis gets even from other
Republicans you know people that are in
the public eye the the Chris Christie's
of the world and such they say things
like he DeSantis Sparks cultural Wars
well culture wars are really important
because a word for the culture matters
culture matters so yes we should be
fighting these wars I think so much of
what we talk about is
um dismissed by the left and we let them
dismiss it we let them say oh this
doesn't matter but it does matter and we
should be talking about it all the time
I think that the schools and the fight
for our schools is so important
Pedro took to Carol's point and to
Jordan's Point MSNBC right now and
Donald Trump and Mike Pence and Chris
Christie and Nikki Haley are all on the
same side of Disney against DeSantis
right now all DeSantis did was even the
playing field he got rid of crony
capitalism which apparently the leftists
and now Trump are for it's incredible
actually
yeah it's not only incredible but it's
also in order to do this Trump has to
repudiate his own position as as the
culture Warrior right the one who was
saving us from the extremes the left
he's now rooting for Disney and I think
that's that's problematic for two
reasons one like you and this is the
point that I actually keep highlighting
uh because I think it's it's powerful
and it cuts across both aisles and
that's that really this is this is as
much it is a culture War thing obviously
like Disney was pushing these radical
ideas
um on kids through their programming but
it's also a question of who rules
are corporations above any
accountability right do they get to say
do they get to do whatever they want
because I think you have to go back here
and remember that this started with the
um the the parental rights and Education
Act Right which was really popular in
Florida for obvious reasons
and Disney was not happy with it and
basically said you know we don't care
that Floridians like this bill uh that
protects families
from from the extreme to the left we're
going to do everything in our power to
to to kill it and if it passes we're
going to we're going to basically engage
in economic Warfare against politicians
by by withholding donations
from from people that have basically
Been instrumental to Disney's success
right so there's no kind of there's no
sense of humility from the company and
so DeSantis said no actually
corporations don't get to do whatever
they want Floridians are actually in
charge of their own State and Disney
doesn't get to push around the the
entire state government
and I think I think when you frame it
like that what Trump and Haley and Pence
are doing becomes even more disgusting
they're siding with a corporation that
basically has said like we rule not you
the people of Florida right and the
funny part the interesting part is so
DeSantis is going against the
corporations I thought the left-hated
corporations he's going against the
donor class which is not happy I thought
politicians weren't supposed to be owned
by donors and he went from winning his
first election by 30 000 votes to 1.6
million so he's clearly doing what the
people want Carol right there was a
Nikki Haley quote where she said
something like he's such a hypocrite
because he took money from Disney and
he's fighting in any way it's like yeah
he took money from Disney and he's
fighting them anyway it's amazing you
should do that you should try that you
know
um also the other Nikki Haley line and
you know I actually I quite like Nikki I
have nothing against her um but I think
that she's gotten into a battle here
that makes no sense and it and not just
her obviously you know all the other
people Donald Trump Mike Pence Chris
Christie I think that the fight that
they're fighting is just makes no sense
to me obviously they should be on
DeSantis aside but she said something
like oh Disney move Disney World to
South Carolina the thing that worries me
about that is like do you really have no
concept of how hard it would be to move
Disney World do you not know that this
enormous thing exists I think with
buildings and communities and all sorts
of stuff around it like do you think
we're throwing it on the back of a
pickup truck and driving it over to
South Carolina can you be president when
you don't know stuff like that I'm not
so sure well also is the implication and
again I I like Nikki too personally and
and professionally but is the
implication oh you will then give them
special benefits in South Carolina that
you won't give other companies because
that's all that's all he took away uh
but speaking of DeSantis and just just
basically just doing what's right it
doesn't have to be packaged in in
anything that fancy here he is yesterday
on uh you know that we are not going to
be transiting these kids I mean if
you're taking off the private parts of
some 15 year old kid you know you should
go to jail for that uh this just totally
unacceptable one of the things we did in
that bill though is we're giving the
victims the ability to sue the
Physicians so if you've gone through
this as a 16 year old or a 15 year old
now you're 24 25 and you have all this
irreversible damage you bring suit
against them because they violated the
Hippocratic Oath they put their ideology
ahead of evidence-based medicine
Pedro everyone knows this is right
everyone knows that people are afraid to
say it but everyone knows this should
not be being done to Children it really
is as simple as that I think I think you
should ask yourself uh David what would
a rhino do differently than what the
status is doing like that's that's the
level of the discourse right now right
there it's funny because they're they're
simultaneously there are two different
attacks on the standards right now one
is that he's beholden to big money and
that's bad for him and the second one is
that his his fights with Disney and his
willingness to actually believe in
things uh is going to hurt his support
with donors and that's bad for him these
both of these lines of attack are being
used at the same time against DeSantis
there was this story in the financial
times about some big uh donor who said
that he was really turned off by the
fact that the sand this the Santa Sky
actually seems to believe in the things
that he fights for in this particular
cultural and social issues and I don't
like that that makes me uncomfortable
and and the Trump people were sharing it
like it was like man this is this is
proof the the donors are turning on him
and the next day it's like you know this
guy is a real Trojan Horse he's
controlled entirely by the donors that
yesterday you know you said he there uh
he was pissing off because he's willing
to actually take on these fights I mean
it's insane uh but I think it also just
shows that despite all the rhetoric
that's coming out of the Trump campaign
because that's ultimately what this is
about right
um they're they're deeply intimidated by
him despite the the talk about National
polls which are I think are irrelevant
at this point at this this early uh in
in in the race I guess
um I think they're afraid of him you
don't act like this you don't talk about
the guy every single day you don't
attack him from every conceivable angle
even when they contradict unless you're
actually intimidated by the guy and you
think that he poses a real threat to you
well to that point I want to show you
this ad that I saw literally about a
half hour before we started the show
this is a Donald Trump ad so he posted
this himself on Instagram and we've got
DeSantis doing all of the things he set
out to do one at a time just knocking
down dominoes you may not agree with all
of them I personally disagree with what
he did moving up abortion from 15 weeks
to six that's a personal disagreement I
have and that's fine but he's
accomplishing everything he set out to
do donors be damned here's what Trump
put up this morning and just see if you
think there's a little difference in
tone and Direction and the rest of it
Ron DeSantis was struggling big time in
his primary race for governor of Florida
polls revealed DeSantis was failing so
bad he was losing by a staggering 17
points then DeSantis was saved by the
endorsement of President Trump Trump's
support was so powerful just two days
after the endorsement DeSantis took a
commanding lead and had propelled him to
being elected I'd like to thank our
president for standing by me when it
wasn't necessarily the smart thing to do
you're welcome Ron unfortunately instead
of being grateful DeSantis is now
attacking the very man who saved his
career isn't it time DeSantis remembers
how he got to where he is make America
great again big league so good build the
wall then Mr Trump said you're fired I
love that part truth is there's only one
person who can make America great again
Carol I want to give the devil his due
here Trump did help DeSantis become
governor first time around he endorsed
them and helped him there's no doubt
about it I also voted for Trump last
time I'm pretty sure both of you did too
but this thing where he has to be
grateful there's no message there
there's no reason to vote for Trump
there it's that you're scared of
DeSantis and should DeSantis just bow
forever I just don't think it works
I don't understand the whole argument
from the Trump campaign and I wrote this
in a piece a few weeks ago about this
but you know the argument that DeSantis
is this horrible globalist you know
Rhino donor shill also I want full
credit for his governorship and he
should just wait four years
right and and he should wait and then
we'll support him then because then
it'll be okay to support this globalist
chill
um and look the Trump campaign is
clearly afraid of Ron DeSantis the media
is clearly afraid of Ron DeSantis I
don't blame them I really see something
in him that I don't see in a lot of
politicians he is a juggernaut he is
this revolutionary character where he is
making some serious changes and the
people who oppose him should be worried
because I don't see him losing on a lot
of fronts um it doesn't mean that'll
never happen it doesn't mean that you
know DeSantis is going to run away with
this nomination I think Donald Trump is
a formidable opponent and it will be an
uphill climb
um but the idea that the Trump campaign
is not worried about him is just not
jiving with the reality of the way that
they're behaving and you know I don't
know if Pedro's gonna get into this but
the comments on that article on that
video are just all pro DeSantis here let
me let me actually show you we have a
screen capture so they disabled they
limited the comments right after putting
this up within about 10 or 15 minutes
all of the comments uh were negative and
defending DeSantis and going after Trump
and you know basically saying this isn't
working and this is nonsense and you've
gotta you know there's a case to be made
for Trump he refuses to make it so as
you can see on the bottom there I
actually I can't quite see it on the
screen it says that they're limited or
something to that effect so that's from
the Trump account uh that's from Team
Trump himself uh Pedro he's not making a
case for himself he's trying to make an
anti-case but yeah
yeah no that's right and by the way the
same thing happened when uh Donald Trump
Jr took a kind of very similar line of
attack against DeSantis and posted it on
Instagram oh yeah they did the same
thing yeah and I I actually uploaded it
to Twitter just scrolling through an
endless stream of negative comments
people either outright you know
attacking him for what he said or saying
I support both people I don't understand
why Trump you know I don't understand
why you guys are attacking the Santas
but they were overwhelmingly negative
and it's interesting because again this
this just seems to be a kind of social
media phenomenon the kind of DeSantis is
over and he's a traitor and stuff
um it's it's mostly on Twitter uh
because we've also seen this live right
when Trump at rallies tries to attack
the scientist the audience goes silent
yeah even on Instagram it doesn't work
it's basically just truth social and
Twitter which on the one hand true
social is the Trump platform and on the
other hand it's easy to manipulate
Twitter uh you know there's there's this
article and this this is not you know
I'm not talking about Russian Bots but
there was an article that I think
correctly pointed out that there
actually does seem to be this kind of
organized social media effort
specifically on Twitter to generate what
looks like overwhelming support like I I
noticed that whenever I tweet about
um DeSantis or Trump I get instant
negative replies from like low follower
accounts it's very bizarre but then when
you do the same exact content on
Instagram it's just real people who are
saying this is ridiculous knock it off
and it's fascinating and I think that
the the point that you're making about
how basically Trump is running on it's
uh I'm owed something I'm sorry that's
loser talk losers talk about what
they're owed and this whole thing of
like I made DeSantis all me Trump
oversaw losses in 2018 2020 and 2022.
DeSantis you know you could say with the
help of trump turned a win into a bigger
win and delivered for his constituents
what did Trump do with with the
Electoral Capital that Americans gave
him he pushed a jailbreak legislation
um he pushed amnesty he was bragging
about I mean think back to like the
Breitbart headlines amnesty Dawn Trump
bragging about pushing a bigger amnesty
than anything Obama had considered and
that was being pushed even to the end of
his administration and there was talk
internally about doing it either at the
end of his first Administration or early
in the second Administration
I think that's really important and by
the way in order to attack the because
Trump knows this is all True by the way
and in order to attack you know the the
image of DeSantis as a winner because he
is Trump recently pointed out that the
Santas also endorsed Carrie like who is
a loser in other words Trump to Trump
toss Carrie lake under the bus to take a
shot at DeSantis and by the way he did
the same thing two weeks ago when he got
those 12 Florida legislators to come to
Mar-A-Lago to endorse him the next
morning he put out this insane
anti-florida diatribe basically making
them all look like fools several people
who I like a lot including Byron
Donald's it's like what like he just
threw you under the bus dude Carol am I
am I crazy but I do think there's a
there's an out here and the out here
would be that over the next couple weeks
as DeSantis gains momentum and people
are just like you know what this is the
competent guy he's younger it's a real
team it's no circus it's what everyone
said that they wanted out of trump it's
it's serious policy without the crazy
tweets and all that that Trump might
like if if anyone on Trump's team is
watching this like the out that still
makes you the hero here is just to be
like you know what I have sciatica I
twisted my ankle I can't do it and but
there is a guy that's pretty good and
I've gone a little harsh on him but
actually I take it back because my
family and me and all my grandchildren
live in his State many of them moved
here because of him during covid and
let's do this together and let's save
America it's like there's such a nice
ending that's so obvious here but can he
take it can he take it there's no way
he'll take it I I thought that there was
no reason for Donald Trump to run this
time I you know I I had met him at
Mar-A-Lago he seemed like his life was
going fantastically after you know after
leaving the White House his life just
seems so much better he was so much
calmer happier
um and I I kept thinking like this guy
could be king maker he can be that role
that he thinks he played for Ron
DeSantis he could literally come into
races and be like this is my guy and and
that guy can go on to win and he can he
can play that role for so many different
candidates potentially
um but instead he decided no he needs he
has scores to settle and he wants to run
again from my perspective this run makes
no sense but look he he wants to do it
again like that's fine
um I I would also say that the way that
the media is going after DeSantis
they're really treating him like the
front runner the piece in political
today where they really go hard against
um Casey DeSantis getting quotes from
like Roger Stone about how she's Lady
Macbeth and then this this writer goes
on for several paragraphs about how the
comparison actually does fit
um and it just I I find it all so
disgusting but the the fact is that
they're doing this to DeSantis and not
Trump right now and there's a reason for
that I've been saying it for weeks
everybody's going after DeSantis MSNBC
and Trump are on the same time uh on the
same side Pedro first appearance last
word
yeah well I I could not help but notice
the the hilarity of Politico basically
observing a healthy marriage uh between
Casey and Rhonda Sanderson basically
writing an article about why it's
problematic and then quoting uh getting
a comment from Roger Stone for that
story Stone a guy who has uh allegedly
been very active in swinger circles and
put out ads asking for men to sleep with
his wife uh but I think that the issue
is is that the the the enemy of the
people to use the Trump uh to use the
term that Trump coined about the media
is actually in the tank with Trump
against DeSantis because they know that
he's actually a far greater threat to
them and he also won't give them access
he won't give Maggie Haberman exclusive
interviews on demand and they hate him
for it
yeah that's absolutely right he said to
MSNBC you lie about me constantly we're
not going to do this anymore however I
will continue to do this with you guys
I've enjoyed it thank you Pedro for your
first appearance Carol you're welcome
back anytime thank you we've got a post
game show in about 37 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com everybody else
have a great weekend we'll be back on
Monday
[Music]
foreign